one reason I wanted to call it the
politics of catastrophe is that there is
a I think a false dichotomy between
natural and man-made disasters that
people have in their heads and so they
think of a a pandemic as an actual
disaster but a war as a man-made
disaster and the book argues taking its
cue from a March's Sen's work on famines
that that dichotomy is a false one and
that disastrous events while they may
have natural points of origin are only
as disastrous as we make them
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from Magic
so it's a great pleasure to be uh
welcoming today a renowned scholar a
thinker uh really one of my favorite
intellectuals I think it's safe to call
you know a public intellectual of the
first and highest order it's great
pleasure to have you here you're joining
us from Stanford is that correct sir
that is right uh Brian I'm uh on a
rather sleepy campus we're relatively
few people are around no students as yet
well I have a sort of a mixed history
with with Stanford it almost caused my
Doom uh because I was fired the only
time I've ever been fired in my life was
from Stanford University we're not going
to talk about that though it led to me
talking to you in some ways though so it
couldn't have been all bad and uh I'll
I'll save that for another day but but I
want to start by asking you first and
foremost to do that which you're never
supposed to do but I always say what
else can you do but judge a book by its
cover and we're here celebrating the
paperback release of this really
phenomenal book that I read but I really
enjoyed listening to because you
narrated it which is which is wonderful
and and it's called Doom it's got a very
a cheerful title so if you wouldn't mind
showing the book the politics of
catastrophe I feel like you're under
selling it a little bit it's so rich
with science with history with a
reverent wit with humor I mean for a
book about Doom it was really a pleasure
to read what is the meaning of the title
and the cover illustration my friend
foreign
well I think you should judge a book by
its cover actually I spend a lot of time
thinking about covers but this one was
probably a mistake uh so the idea of the
book was uh to write a general history
of disaster which didn't really exist
all disasters man-made and natural all
in one place and I you know I say to
people when I talk about this book if
you can think of a disaster that's not
in this book I'll give you a free book
and the idea of the the book jacket was
that I just love the image of this guy
sinking apart with the Raging Wildfire
behind him uh was taken a few years ago
uh in Oregon I think and I I persuaded
my American Publishers to go with that
uh as as as an image and it it also was
supposed to Signal it's not a book about
covert although covert is is in it it's
a book about disasters generally but I
think it was probably a mistake because
it doesn't really say that it's a
history book and and so the paper bag
looks radically different uh and the
paperback is I think a much better uh
jacket and I have to give credits my
German Publishers uh DVA who said this
is a history book it needs to look like
a history book uh the book I think uh
isn't the depressing read that its title
might imply I think I might have wanted
to write a bestseller uh in the sort of
Markham Gladwell range I'd have called
it fun uh uh the politics of partying or
something like that and that would have
been a great read for for the
post-pandemic American public but it's a
book about disaster on our relationship
to it and because I'm from Glasgow the
west of Scotland uh the kind of gallows
humor is is part of how I relate to
disaster and so it's not in fact a
dismal read I hope in places it's in the
maybe Macabre way quite quite fun but I
wanted to get our strange relationship
to disaster and the Advent of covert
gave gave it a perfect Peg yeah yeah and
it truly is I mean the one you know just
in all seriousness that the only thing I
would take issue is it's the subtitles
the politics but really you make a very
convincing case that you know politics
is only partially the blame and I wonder
if that was uh you know born of the
moment in which it was written as I
understand you were in Montana
squirreled away with your lovely family
and uh writing it and amidst the you
know feigning you know Fender a decadal
moments of 2020 right after the election
or around the election kovid was still
in the news no vaccine on the horizon
um and so politics obviously was in the
news uh when you were writing it but
when it came out
um you know I wonder if that really
summarizes or does Justice to the full
breath and scope I mean you take a
panoramic view of it long before the
politics of the state really made made
an impact so maybe you can capitulate
relate a little bit to the readers that
might not be familiar with it yet
although hopefully they'll get the book
in all its forms you know what is the
role of politics how much can man really
do are politicians really do to avert
presage or predict or remedy a doom
disaster type scenario well less than
the public and the media think I think
that's part of the reason I gave it that
subtitle one reason I wanted to call it
the politics of catastrophe is that
there is a I think a false dichotomy
between natural and man-made disasters
that people have in their heads and so
they think of a a pandemic as a natural
disaster but a war as a man-made
disaster and the book argues taking its
cue from a March's Sen's work on famines
that that dichotomy is a false one and
that disastrous events while they may
have natural points of origin are only
as disastrous as we make them so let's
take the example of the pandemic whether
you subscribe to the lovely hypothesis
or not doesn't really matter even if the
the new virus was a natural zoonotic uh
mutation at the way that the Chinese
Authority authorities handled the
outbreak in Wuhan
suppressing information about it and
essentially lying about human to human
transmission meant that it was a
pandemic it could have been contained
and perhaps in a society with greater
Freedom it would have been contained but
right from its Origins you can't
understand covid without the politics of
the Chinese Communist party and then you
ask the question well why does this
virus have such different impacts on
different countries why is there almost
no excess mortality in Taiwan which is
right next door to the People's Republic
and very high mortality in say the
United States an even higher mortality
relatively in some Latin American
countries that that can't be explained
in in terms of I don't think in in
biological terms it's the same virus
basically and there really aren't big
human genetic differences explaining the
outcomes the outcomes have to do
with very great variation in public
health policy and one of the arguments
that was very live in 2020 when I was
writing the book was that it was all
Donald Trump's fault in the United
States uh Jim fallaz read a piece of the
Atlantic saying it's pilot error that
that if the pilots uh incompetent the
plane crashes and I really thought that
couldn't be right and so part of the
motivation towards the end of the book
is to say it's highly unlikely that one
can attribute that much agency that much
importance to the president of the
United States it's much more plausible
that this is a failure of of the Centers
for Disease Control uh or the Department
of Health and Human Services it's a
failure of the public health bureaucracy
just as success in Taiwan was success on
the part of the bureaucracy this is a
long-winded way of saying that most
disasters have a kind of man-made or
political character even a volcanic
eruption is not an entirely natural
disaster if you've chosen to build a
bloody great city right at the foot of
the volcano and then you rebuild it
after the eruption as if there's not
going to be another one at some future
date so that's that's part of the the
thinking there I'm not a scientist but
of course a lot of Sciences involved in
A Book Like This what I can write about
incredibly is the ways in which human
decision making fails to manage the risk
or the uncertainty around mutations of
viruses or geological events yeah and
actually that was one of the more
depressing aspects of it to me was
um given the amount uh the scope the
budget the the ascription of agency I
remember January 15 2020 I was at a
Shabbat dinner with some friends and I
just been invited to visit a cosmology
experiment in uh of all places Tibet in
that coming April and my friend uh said
well you better think a little bit you
know about that because there's this you
know new disease called coven I'd heard
a little bit about it and he said yeah
you know the Chinese are they're pretty
amazing you know they built a hospital
in eight days that you know can uh can
double as a prison and and it can fit
you know 8 000 people and I was like oh
that's kind of interesting and and then
you know two months later of course all
hell breaks loose including here in
America and I was thinking if my friend
you know some uh yenta at the Shabbat
dinner can know this when we have you
know the billion dollar three letter
agencies of all countries I mean is this
a failure of you know truly of just the
bloating the size of God I mean how
could the NSA the CIA the FBI you know
the uh NHS whatever in in in England
they all failed with trillions of
dollars a budget are these things just
intrinsically I mean it's not an
asteroid impact it's not you know it's
it's a virus that we had spy satellites
we could have if my friend knew in other
words they were building a hospital yeah
why didn't we have enough masks I mean
what do you attribute what can we
attribute that to well the the simple
answer is it wasn't all because the
president was a populist
with uh an impulse control problem the
failure is clearly much further down the
chain of of command within the public
health bureaucracy and that's a
recurrent theme of the book that the
point of failure is not always at the
top and it actually quite seldom is
right at the top I got that from Richard
Feynman yeah I was going to say the
Challenger disaster yeah really and
we'll we'll get to Richard fireman at
the end of this class I I sort of trail
that for your listeners who probably are
Feynman fans that's right we're going to
get so measurable I got as an epiphany
feynman's insight into the Challenger is
really not being uh attributable to
Ronald Reagan it was attributable to the
NASA bureaucracy and one person in
particular but in the case of covert
CDC clearly did much worse than early
CDC in say
1957-58 when there was a pretty serious
influenza pandemic despite being now a
much larger organization with the much
larger budget and and you you can delve
into the failures in the UK in the same
way and that that increasingly is
happening I don't think we'll ever have
a full public inquiry into the failure
of the U.S Public Health bureaucracy of
the salt that we probably need I mean we
need a sort of 911 Commission to
understand why the the guy whose job it
was to be the under secretary for
preparedness admitted in 2018 that the
pandemic preparedness plan wouldn't work
and why nothing was done about that we
we really need to know more about that
but my read based on public publicly
available information in 2020 was that
uh key parts of the public health
bureaucracy Sim simply screwed up and
the most obvious example is testing why
did the Taiwanese control the outbreak
at the beginning when the population was
at its most vulnerable because they very
quickly got to a point where they could
test on on a large scale and we utterly
failed to do that in fact CDC prevented
testing being available by insisting
that they monopolize it shutting down
private initiative and that meant that I
think I probably had covert at the
beginning because I had been in in Asia
right at the beginning of January I was
sick as a dog in late January and
February but I couldn't get a test even
on the Stanford campus which you would
have thought of as a pretty cutting-edge
place for medical science and that was
just one of multiple failures I think
the bureaucracy knew as surely as their
financial counterparts in 2007 that they
were not ready for a crisis and yet they
sat with their meaning English 36-page
pandemic preparedness plan and waited
for the disaster to strike and I think
kind of hoping that it wouldn't strike
on their watch that that's my broad take
and I think this is a generally relevant
point about disaster whether you're
talking about the Challenger of the
Titanic or for that matter World War One
any disaster we're very inclined to say
blame it on the president blame it on
the king blame it on the emperor that's
a sort of powerful human impulse uh and
and in fact people at the top of
hierarchies of power quite want us to
attribute power to them but it's the
same point Tolstoy makes about Napoleon
and War and Peace he thinks he's really
important he thinks he's in charge but
you can't really explain what's going on
in and around 1812 purely in terms of
his decisions and his orders so in the
same way a disaster really tends to be
magnified by points further down the
chain of command and that that search
for the point of failure was what
motivated me to call it the politics of
catastrophe using the term politics
quite broadly
yeah and I think you make this very
um distinct and and accurate distinction
between you know the politics or maybe
the the the human you know comprehension
of power law type effects and normal
distribution or gaussian distributions
I'm tempted because you're a Scotsman to
call them a Maxwell boltzmann
distributions in honor of the great
James Clerk Maxwell who died too soon
maybe we'll talk about him when I want
to talk about uh social media which
you're quite Adept at
um uh and uh but you know there are in
single individuals who change history
Lee Harvey Oswald uh Hitler uh and then
there are collective things that you
know it takes all societies a whole
Demar you know genocides and and so
forth they're you know partially
collectivist and partially
individualists I wonder if that's you
know kind of the enumeracy as as the
mathematician Palace has called it you
know the failure of the human brain to
really comprehend what is a power law
what is a normal distribution and to to
falsely describe things in the past to
Witchcraft and and spirits and now we
ascribe everything to science and and of
course that that was one of the major
you know kind of thrusts of your earlier
work especially
um you know with your so-called six
killer apps and maybe we can we can talk
a little bit about that do has science
you know uh really lived up to the hope
of its uh you know what it pretended to
be and when you called it a killer app
the scientific method and Medicine those
were two of the three of the six killer
apps that you spoke about
um how have they fared during this
pandemic and and more broadly speaking
are we too reliant on them as as Arthur
C Clarke said any sufficiently Advanced
Technologies indistinguishable from
Magic or are we not Reliant enough and
we're innumerate as Palos might say
well this is a big preoccupation for the
Ferguson family I come from a scientific
family my mother's a physicist and so is
my sister my father was a physician I'm
the black sheep of the family I went
into history which is uh I was reading
the other day has much lower IQ students
I wish I'd known that back in in 1980
when I was applying to Oxford well I
think the the big takeaway here is that
we've made extraordinary advances in our
our scientific understanding as a
species there's just no contest the
medieval peasant even the medieval
Monarch was clueless in the face of the
Black Death by comparison with us and
yet and yet despite these enormous
advances we feared quite poorly in the
face of a not very deadly virus by
historic standards I mean this
definitely wasn't uh anything that could
compare with the uh with the the
mnemonic and Bubonic plague of the 14th
century and I've been struggling to try
to work that problem out
there is a tendency in let's call them
populist circles
to Grumble uh that somehow the
scientists failed but that's not right
I was really impressed by the way
scientists as a global Community
responded to the challenge presented by
the new South cov2 virus and and the new
disease in fact part of what got me
through 2020 was drinking from a fire
hose of scientific publication in too
many disciplines to list in which an
enormous number of people struggled
collectively to understand the nature of
the challenge that was definitely not
the point of failure and of course you
had within an amazingly short space of
time the huge success of of that
vaccines with higher than 90 efficacy in
the phase three trials thick things that
happen after I'd finished writing the
book but which I kind of felt would
happen I had a good feeling about where
those vaccines would come out
so where did things go wrong not I think
uh amongst scientists there were
failures amongst Public Health officials
and scientists who were uh playing a
public public role as advisors and I
think that happened on both sides of the
Atlantic uh and and the reason it
happened I think was that the incentives
meaningfully change when you move from
engaging in science as a vacation
seeking to arrive at truth through
experimental methods and doing policy
and and you could illustrate this with
the case of my near namesake Neil
Ferguson uh the epidemiologist at
Imperial College who's March 2020 paper
set the scene for lockdown policies on
both sides of the Atlantic and what
what's interesting about the case of of
Neil Ferguson is that there were I
thought obvious problems with the paper
and I'm not even a trained scientist in
the assumptions it made about the
infection fatality rate in the
assumptions it made about what measures
would be necessary to contain spread in
his Readiness to think that the Chinese
had got it right with Draconian
lockdowns and I could go on and on but
that paper was seized upon by public
health bureaucracies that were panicking
and by politicians who were suddenly
panicking and it led to a series of
extremely costly policy errors the
biggest flaw was that he another
epidemiologists simply ignored The
Economic Consequences and I'd say
broader social consequences of lockdowns
as a problem as if it really wasn't
their concern and as a result they
massively understated the costs of the
policy that they were recommending and I
think they overstated the benefits so it
wasn't it wasn't so much that bad
science was being done though I think
the model that Ferguson used probably
was deeply flawed it was more that it it
then became very quickly politicized and
led to bad policy choices in which the
trade-offs and that's the central
problem of any policy decision-making
process the trade-offs were just
completely bungled
and not being able to really distinguish
as you make clear in the book you know
the difference between risk and
uncertainty
um we in the scientific you know
experimental uh scientific Community
we're building instruments in foreign
countries in my case in Chile with my
collaboration and we have these risk
registers and they have some expected
you know value of of impact and dollars
and personnel and so forth and you have
to be quite clinical about it but then
you know I'll turn around I'll see some
of the same students that work in my lab
you know uh on their skateboards here in
Southern California you know uh with a
mask on you know no helmet and with a
cell phone you know in front of their
faces they're barreling down the main
you know quad and I just feel like
there's in Trend and these are Highly
Educated uh you know scientifically
literate individuals
um I wonder if that's if it's just you
know the the human nature that we are
just uh we are we are incapable of
grasping as I said you know before a new
point on the book The Power law versus
the normal curve I mean is this just I
mean we obviously have to do something
to to try to counter it but but I think
weighing the true cost benefit analysis
is not something that we're particularly
Adept at doing I know for example I
didn't have Global pandemic on my risk
register you know in 19 and 2019 uh I
don't know too many people that did
um but how do we how do we balance that
need for Freedom we're not wearing a
helmet you know on a skateboard versus
the you know you must wear a mask and
you must get tested how do we balance
that in a western you know weird
so-called weird country like uh the US
what it would help if we taught kids
about probability uh and risk at school
but we don't uh and in fact we make no
attempt
to teach y'all young future citizens
about risk management in any domain yeah
from personal safety to personal finance
we we really allow people to go through
our educational system
without getting them to think in a
probabilistic way about risk and
uncertainty I think that's the first
mistake that we make of course by our
nature we we're evolved Apes uh we we
have a set of of cognitive skills that
are quite well suited to to hostile
environments and so we can sometimes do
the right thing instinctively and
impulsively but in the modern uh
environment of a post-industrial society
a lot of the things that we revolve to
be good at aren't really that useful and
I think your your example of the the
student on the skateboard with the cell
phone and the mask on which of course
there were many people in the same
playing the same part on the Stanford
campus uh cycling around the campus with
masks on um I think that illustrates uh
our our fatally flawed nature uh as a
species and part of the reason for
writing Doom was to get myself to think
in a more rational way about my
predicaments how wrong am I likely to
live at the age of 58 with my background
it's not that comfortable to think about
life expectancy especially and from
Glasgow but you kind of got to do it
we've had a lot of conversation about
this in our household recently since the
attack on Salman Rushdie which was uh
not that long ago my wife Ayan Hersey
Ali has also received multiple death
threats and fat to us over the years for
her work on Islamic extremism and when
the news came through that salmon had
been attacked in that horrible fashion I
could see a yarn very worried deeply
anxious reverting to a state of
fearfulness that I remember from from
years ago and I had to sit down and say
look that the risk never went away not
for salmon rushing not for you it is a
risk but we seek to manage it but the
risk to me of cancer is probably a bit
bigger my friend Andrew Jane just died
at 59 of of cancer and the risk to our
boys of being hit by a car because
they're not that used to traffic is
higher uh than either of these risks and
we should worry much more about that
than we do and so part of the reason for
writing the book Doom is to expose the
fact that for all kinds of strange
reasons we have a cognitive difficulty
when it comes to thinking about risk and
uncertainty we love to fixate on the
wrong things and and we'd like the idea
of cataclysmic disaster we love to watch
movies about that or read books about
that there's always a kind of market for
the movie Contagion in fact people
watching that movie during the early
stages of covert which I yeah I think a
lot of journalists were getting some of
their ideas about uh fomite and all the
stuff that turned out to be nonsense
that's all in that movie and I I yeah I
don't think they did the scientific
research the end of the world is
fascinating it is medium-sized disasters
of the sort were quite likely to
encounter kind of boring and the
statistics of our risk at any given
stage of Life which are widely available
uh just people don't really they don't
internalize them even if you kind of
show them and I used to show my students
these risks when talking back in the
post-9 11 period about terrorism I'd
kind of try to get them to think about
this
it's not something that comes naturally
to us and that was what motivated me to
write the book partly to explore my own
relationship to mortality and risk the
final point I'll make is that we don't
like how big the domain of uncertainty
is and this is the point others have
made Nasim Talib made ages ago in the
Black Swan we really want much more to
be calculable risk and much less to be
incalculable uncertainty than is in fact
the case and power laws are helpful in
this respect especially if you live in
California because you know there's
going to be some bloody great earthquake
at some point but you don't know when
and you don't know how big and there's
just no way of of getting a handle on
that except that it can happen that's as
far as we can really go and so so many
things inhabit that domain including it
turns out Wars uh the the things that
historians are interested in which are
the big disastrous events
because they occupy this realm of
uncertainty they're governed by
parallels or they're randomly
distributed in the case of Wars you can
see that's such a fundamental point
about history that it should be Central
to what we as historians do rather than
a sort of afterthought if it appears at
all
right yeah and just paying attention as
you list you know you keep
um mentioning you know where do these
different pandemics disasters fall in
terms of the spectrum of distribution of
events that claimed even a half a
percent of human life and I'm not you
know obviously uh every human life is
precious we we don't have to get into
that debate but but I remember thinking
you know throughout this book that
there's kind of this commonality and and
you end the book with I don't think it's
much of a spoiler but you end the book
with um I forget the author the Journal
of the plague year uh the quote yes and
the quote you know being basically like
a hundred thousand died in London in 65
but I'm still alive and I I found myself
wondering you know you as you just
mentioned with your family your children
your wife
um you know how how do we balance this
kind of it seems to me that quote the
plague year quote is along the lines of
you know Ernest Becker's denial of death
you know that they're they're sort of a
coping mechanism that human beings have
to put off you know the thoughts of our
eventual we know we're going gonna die
in fact I think that's what Homo Sapien
means it means we are the only creature
that knows that our existence is more is
finite and yet and yet we we want to
balance that with you know the Memento
Mori with the denial of death so how do
you personally how do you how do you
strike that balance between the
preciousness you describe yourself in
your earlier years in your first
marriage as a workaholic
um now you've got these young children
that you treasure your your wife um that
you that you're so deeply committed to
how do you balance that personally the
the desire to have all this output
um but also to spend time with your kids
you're not going to get that back how do
you balance the Memento Mori with the
with the denial of death I guess that's
the succinct way
well the first point I'll make is that
growing up I was born in 1964 uh with my
grandfather's uh having served in the
world wars
I was aware in a way that I suspect most
Californian kids today aren't aware of
the proximity of death that it was luck
that had got my grandfathers through and
the first book that I I published had to
do with the first World War
there's a song that the soldiers sang
and I quoted in Doom in the trenches on
the eve of the battle of the Somme and
it's a parody of a Salvation Army him
the bells of hell go tingling a ling for
you but not for me
and that song captures how a late teens
early twenties British man coped with
the prospect of an incredibly risky
attack on the German lines in in 1916
uh oh death where is thy sting a ling a
ling o grave thy Victory they laughed in
the face of imminent death I was haunted
by that as a as a boy and I never really
ceased to be aware of that
the proximity of death but the need to
laugh at it I remember reading Hamlet as
a teenager at school and realizing that
that is a play in which a man comes to
terms with mortality that's really the
point of the play then I walk into the
Fitzwilliam Museum in Cambridge I'm in
my mid-20s I I think I had I had my
first academic job
in Cambridge and there in the
Fitzwilliam museum is a is a painting uh
by an Italian artist Salvatore Rosa
depicting the the death of most of his
family in an outbreak of plague in in
Naples in the mid 17th century and there
is an inscription on the painting which
sums up The Human Condition more
succinctly than anything I've ever seen
uh and it is uh conceptio cool
partnersimori conception is sin birth is
pain life is work and death is
inevitable and I remember seeing that
and thinking that's it that sums it all
up
and now we must try to live as best we
can as if it's more than that and so I
think as with the soldiers in the
trenches
My Philosophy has been
be aware
of the finite nature of Life be aware
that it could be cut off cruelly
and in with that awareness in your mind
in the back of your mind but try to
achieve as much as you possibly can
now
I hope that I I'm selfless at least some
of the time I know that I've been
motivated by an intellectual ambition
from a very early age to try to
understand the world better that's what
sent me down the path of History because
what seemed to me elusive about the
world as I was growing up was was not
the kind of thing my my mother and
sister were interested in it felt to me
as if the movements of heavenly bodies
or of particles
were not the real problem
the real problem was the tendency of
human beings to murder one another and
to work out why that kept happening was
a for me a more powerful imperative
reading Tolstoy was a big reason why I
became an historian why on Earth did the
Russian people and the French people
Slaughter one another that's really the
central question of that book so I've
tried to understand the world better
with that big question in the back of my
mind and that that's the thing that gets
me out of bed in the morning and at the
same time I've I've tried and I hope
I've succeeded in some measure to be a
good son uh a good husband and and a
good father and a good friend because
those are the things that that really
matter in the end because you're not
going to get your gravestone doesn't
have a bibliography on it you'll not see
many of those right you know it doesn't
actually list your Publications your age
indexes it doesn't usually fit well
that's the whole resume virtues versus
eulogy virtues that I think they David
Brooks and Rabbi Sullivan had spoken
about Adam one versus atom two I guess
the uh the the kind of thought that does
give me some
um hope maybe to segue into our
conversation about science fiction and
maybe using what you just said you
you've often yeah I mean you you
mentioned this this fact that you know
this this fascinating notion that human
beings kill each other and in my field
there's this obsession with finding
alien life I mean the James Webb Space
Telescope was just uh recently launched
and is returning spectacular images
recently this when we're recording this
in late summer
um they detected uh the signature of
carbon dioxide on an exoplanet called
with with the Winsome name uh wasp 36B I
think it's called Uh I was going to call
my third son that that name but I didn't
anyway uh the uh but the the hope that
we're gonna find extraterrestrial life
and that somehow it's going to be
benevolent not like uh you know the
three body problem that you quote from
so so deliciously and delightfully and I
did have the honor of meeting sentinelu
when he came oh you did Diego uh just
before the pandemic actually a
phenomenal intellect and writer uh but
uh but you know the assumption is that
even if they're not benevolent at least
there's life that will give us some sort
of meaning and intensity and I've said
this I said this in Lex Friedman's
podcast when I was on a few months back
I said I don't think anything will
happen and I actually have a proof for
that because in 1996 Bill Clinton stood
on the White House lawn and said we
found material from Mars that seems to
indicate byproducts of respiration uh
from Martian meteor microbes and people
went out Bosnia you know Herzegovina war
that you discussed that's kept going uh
just as you described and doom
um I don't think a damn thing would
change if we discovered life on another
planet tomorrow uh maybe it would change
for a week or two what what do you think
about the prospects for the impact on on
history of a discovery such as uh the
credible existence just technological
life just of life in general in the
universe outside of Earth well if it
were to be discovered I'd be terrified
because I think you see Shin is on to
something uh with his uh his theory of
cosmic sociology which is in the second
volume of the the trilogy uh the uh the
the Dark Forest
the argument there for those who don't
know the book is that if we if one does
discover intelligent life one should
immediately seek to destroy it before it
destroys you and even if you're
technologically ahead of it now there is
no guarantee that it won't overtake you
at some future date
it's it's an extraordinarily brilliant
Insight maybe it's just an insight into
the way the modern Chinese mind works
but the idea that that that new life
would be benign
is one that we must definitely resist it
seems to me much more probable that it
would either intentionally or
unintentionally be very bad for us uh
the second thing I'd say is that if it
were to turn out to be a good or appear
good in the first uh instance there's
plenty of Science Fiction that tells you
it'll turn out to be bad later so B
be very afraid even if they seem nice
maybe be especially afraid
but you're right whatever we discovered
would not radically alter our ways of
behavior and Leadership makes that point
too once it's clear that the tricolorans
are going to invade Earth they have
collaborators
amongst radical environmentalists and
nihilists who actually think Humanity
should be eradicated so we wouldn't all
come together uh in the face of a Common
Thread any more than we did in the face
of sarsko V2 stroke covert 19. uh I mean
in fact what's fascinating about the way
we behave as a species is that we can
keep our old feuds going even in the
face of a common enemy that that makes
the experiment the natural experiments
of 20 20 21 really interesting if
anything we in fact became more divided
both domestically and internationally
than we had been in 2019 doesn't make me
terribly optimistic about that that
scenario but I'm going to go with the
very low probability view I can't help
feeling that
you know we've been looking at uh for
this for a while and like you I was
excited by the exoplanet with with signs
of of well not life but maybe the
potential for life but I I I don't know
I just suppose it's it's just can't help
feeling the you know here I am 58 and
I'm sure I was thinking about this when
I was a kid 50 years ago
um yeah yeah probability has to be
pretty low at this point even even
though yeah I mean tell me I'm wrong
yeah and and I think that there is a
value to you know speculating obviously
uh you know and what I do is uh uh
although I prefer actually science uh
science facts science non-fiction uh to
science fiction uh even though I am the
associate director of the Arthur C
Clarke Center for human imagination
we'll get to him in a bit but there's uh
something of a podcasters Trifecta
lately you know which uh I don't know if
you're familiar with but aliens which we
covered
um the simulation hypo emphasis which is
which is typically I had on Nick Bostrom
recently uh but I want to skip ahead
because you're so not knowledgeable
about so many different topics but the
third in the trifecta is of course
Bitcoin uh and you uh of course are
known for the ascent of money this
phenomenal award-winning series that you
did back uh decade plus ago I can't
believe how long ago it was it seems
like it was just yesterday you have an
aged appreciably uh whatever you're
taking I want to get a a dose of that
Neil but um you did your thesis on
hyperinflation in the 1920s in Germany
and I wonder like do you see Echoes of
of both the dangers of of hyperinflation
rearing its head around the world right
now uh or do you see the benefit for
something like a Bitcoin like object to
to you know prevent such such rampant uh
uh hyperinflation scenarios that you are
so uh well studied in what are your
thoughts now on bitcoin I I haven't read
much um I mean not to say that's just a
lack in my scholarship I I have I read
in late 2020 about uh some of your
thoughts on it but what what are your
thoughts uh recent thoughts about
Bitcoin well I updated your sense of
money uh in 2018 on its 10th anniversary
and published a couple of new chapters
in that new edition one of which was
about cryptocurrency
and in the course of writing that I
changed my mind prior to then prior to
2017 I'd been
pretty much a skeptic in the standard
way that uh economists tend to be
uh and ignored my then teenage son when
he had urged me to buy Bitcoin at 300
bucks
and then as he got older and I got wiser
uh and he was graduating from high
school I said why don't you come out to
Stanford and work here for a bit and
like help me understand this so we did a
little bit of collaboration Lachlan and
I and I came around to A A View that
that's a little idiosyncratic but let me
let me run this past you as a financial
historian
I think I I take a different view from
economists of how these things work
economists really don't want lots of
changes in the institutional
infrastructure of the economy because
they they want to take that for granted
and focus on uh on other things uh on
movements of of income and and
employment they're not they're not even
that interested in money anymore
I'm interested in the way financial
institutions change over time and they
change a lot and they change in a very
evolutionary way
and it became clear to me that we were
probably living through a financial
Revolution propelled by the internet and
it was highly unlikely that we would
continue to have the financial methods
of payment that predated the internet
for very much longer it can't be
rational for us to be typing credit card
numbers into random websites to pay for
stuff so point one the financial system
is bound to evolve uh and to evolve to
produce payments that are more naturally
native to the internet Point number two
you can do things that you couldn't do
before with the Advent of blockchain and
the idea of having a peer-to-peer system
of payment that doesn't require third
party verification of any kind is it's
an old idea but it's now a possible idea
third point if you've come up with this
novel technology all that really matters
is adoption
uh that's the key to the spread of a
technology does it get adopted on a
sufficient scale and I think the answer
to that is clearly yes it already has
been adopted on a pretty large scale big
enough I think to be pretty hard to kill
in the case of of Bitcoin and I think it
has the potential to get even larger so
in 2018 I made the following observation
if every millionaire
in the world had uh 0.2 percent
of uh his or her wealth in Bitcoin the
price would be I'm not going to do this
from memory something like 17 000. and
if it went to one percent then the price
would be more like 70
000 and that's the range that one should
probably think about in the near term
and that's kind of the range within
which Bitcoin has fluctuated over the
past couple of years and my sense is
that we're now in one of those lulls
during which it will be decided partly
by legislation and regulation how much
adoption there is in the next phase and
that's that's the that's the uncertainty
at the moment and I think the same
applies more generally to decentralized
finance it applies uh to all those
things that have been built on top of of
ethereum I'm broadly an optimist about
this because I don't see the status quo
as defensible or or Bank dominated
fiat-dominated system is too defective
in too many ways to survive but it's not
yet certain to me that it will be
replaced by a blockchain based system of
Finance when centralized AI platforms of
the sort that evolved in China might
just be more convenient and and easier
and cheaper to run so that that seems
like the real uncertainty which of the
these two forms decentralized or
centralized ultimately prevails but the
old systems the Legacy system's dying
last thing I'll say which I think is
already something I've said but that the
last last thing I'll say is that of
course there's going to be
hyperinflation in Argentina uh and a
bunch of other countries uh that are in
the process of of blowing up their
currencies in a familiar way
there won't be hyperinflation in the
United States uh in fact we'll we're
sort of barely going to make it into
double-digit inflation the way things
are going uh you'll get double digit
inflation in the UK and elsewhere in
Europe but that's more I think a result
of Supply disruption on the energy side
than of monetary policy but the range of
inflation is much more I think 1970s uh
than most people yeah realize because if
you're young enough that you don't
remember the 1970s then you can't easily
imagine how we could suddenly have got
here after 20 years of two percent or
less than two percent inflation but the
point of financial history is that it
tells you that's what happens and there
was nothing natural about below two
percent inflation it's just I don't
think inflation is the reason for
cryptocurrency and it was always
puzzling to me that the people who were
promoting Bitcoin promoted it as a
solution to the problem of inflation
because of the fixed Supply or that was
the reasoning but you know gold hasn't
really been a great hedge against
inflation in in most of of History so I
mean if you're if your argument is hey
this is just as good as gold this is
digital gold then the reason for selling
it isn't really that it's a hedge
against inflation Bitcoins are hedge
against expropriation uh as gold
generally has been it's just it's form
of of holding your your wealth that is
quite hard for governments to to
confiscate that's why crypto is popular
in places with poor rule of law and and
governments that inclined towards
confiscation the idea that it was a
solution to an inflation problem was
weird particularly in 2008 when
satoshi's paper appeared when inflation
definitely wasn't the problem uh so I
think there's a slight non-sequitur and
a lot of the thinking that goes on about
this just in the same way that and
economists when they say oh well it's
not a store of value and it's not a unit
of account blah blah blah they're
missing the point what people are
interested in is not textbook
definitions of money what they're
interested in is how can I make payments
with the lowest possible transaction
cost and inconvenience and that will be
the question the answer to that question
will determine what emerges as the
dominant payment system
yeah I mean I see it also you know
depressingly it doesn't seem like if it
only got one percent adoption of
millionaires uh globally it doesn't seem
like it could ever have an effect on
inflation almost by definition as a
ballast counterweight what have you and
I've also seen it you know with the with
the shutdowns and I do want to get to I
don't know how much more time you have
left please feel free to interrupt we
can we can cut short any any of these
longer conversations like this every day
Brian this is a pleasure okay it's my
pleasure uh I'm I'm convinced more than
yours but but I want to say with the
with the with the fact that
um you know there there was during the
the recent you know Canadian trucker
strike where you know it was a coinbase
was forced to close and uh you know
doing operations and and there's all
sorts of payment systems that can be
manipulated it doesn't seem like it is
decentralized really Bitcoin itself and
I feel like there is one network that
you know which which you've written
about the powers of network effects and
and I want to get into to that as well
but but thinking about networks I mean
unless you have a benevolent
dictatorship or you have truly
decentralized I don't think as you say
that we'll ever be able to truly claim
that it's that it's you know free from
from Central domination and I wanna I
wanna maybe segue you you mention
briefly you know these kind of world
organizations that play a role perhaps
not as menacing in 2020 as they are now
the wef Davos and so forth uh are are
these entities you know the boogeyman
that that at least on the conservative
right people are making them out to feel
uh you know we hear a lot about Davos
and and Klaus Schwab and and so forth
are they really capable of of of of
impacting or causing any effect on daily
lives here in America let's just be you
know venally uh america-centric
um Can these Boogeyman really affect us
in any way I mean or are they just kind
of a chimerical uh uh meant to enrage
and and just polarize further so that
there's engagement to sell more ads on
on Twitter well the United States is
vastly more power than any of those
public or non-public uh institutions
that you mentioned and it's kind of
comical for Americans who enjoy the
protection of one of the most powerful
empires in history to be worried about a
conference that's held annually in a
Swiss ski resort come on
where is Klaus Schwab's Navy uh I I
can't remember where he keeps his
ballistic missiles it's all stupid it's
stupid because
the reality is that organizations like
the world economic Forum all the
Bilderberg Group uh or the trilateral
commission
I mean I I've attended meetings of all
of these bodies of course I'm part of
the conspiracy
stuff I mean I'm here to to report to
somebody who's highly sympathetic to
what we might call the populist
constituency of Middle America and
here's a report that they actually are
embarrassingly weak uh and confused on
on the whole about what what to do with
the world even if they had power the
world economic Forum meeting of January
2020 was entirely dominated by a
discussion of climate change in its
Global risk report which must have been
prepared the previous year the risk of a
pandemic didn't appear at all and so I
ran around the conference center trying
to persuade people that they should
change the agenda to a pandemic because
that was slightly faster moving than
climate change
note-takers and I was regarded as having
slightly lost my my marbles when I
emailed Schwab display by the way there
are five people listed in the
participants uh booklet from Wuhan you
probably need to warn everybody that
this could be a super spreader event so
no I mean there's there's much less
there uh that meets the eye now in the
book The Square and the tower I tried to
argue that that doesn't mean they're
insignificant because I think it was
quite important that Schwab built the
world economic Forum up as a a network
for promoting ideas about particularly
about free Capital movement
International Investment let's call it
globalization I think that did spread
the the word I think it was important
that Nelson Mandela went to Davos and
was kind of persuaded to ditch socialist
uh goals from the African National
congress's Manifesto but it's
interesting that he was persuaded not by
Klaus Schwab but but actually by the
Chinese people who were there it's like
no forget about socialism that stuff
doesn't work
um but no I think these things matter
but they they don't matter the way the
conspiracy theorists think they matter
in the same way that the the network of
Jewish Bankers which I studied early in
my career at the Rothschilds the
warburgs ETC that was a real thing and
there was a network there and it was
important it played a very big part in
the history of of 19th century uh
industrialization and uh and economic
development but in terms of political
power it was much weaker than all the
conspiracy theorists of that time
claimed and that was made very clear
when uh anti-semitic politicians like
Hitler came to power and very easily
were able to destroy the network of
Jewish Finance so I you know my sense is
that these things are important to study
but if you're going to study them you've
got to keep a sense of perspective and
that's what the conspiracy theorists
don't bother doing acres are not really
studying them at all they're really just
projecting Collective neuroses on
fantasy networks fantasy organizations
that are much more powerful than they
really are that seems very akin to the
you know ascription as you make very
strongly in Doom to want to place blame
on the foot of the most powerful leaders
in in the world and you know as as you
make very clear throughout many of these
you know disasters quote unquote uh uh
they have almost no power and in fact
they serve to undermine their own causes
in many effects I want to turn now to an
ultimate source of power and that's uh
tenure and Academia uh you and I are
members of an August field I always say
you know how do you know that being a
professor is the is the best job in the
known universe uh and it's and it's
because uh it is the only profession
that Neil Armstrong another Neil took up
once he came off of the Moon he became a
professor in Ohio uh I don't know if you
knew that but uh that was the only thing
that could top going to the Moon
literally how is being a professor
impacted you what what part of your
identity whether it was at Harvard or
your work as a fellow and a scholar at
the Hoover institution
what is being a scholar Professor what
does that mean to you as as a man as an
identity as a father how does it impact
you and what do you see as the future of
our profession it's it's over a thousand
years old it really hasn't changed that
much what do you see of the future of
what we do
I became an academic
because I value intellectual freedom
above everything else
and I wanted to be able to pursue my
ideas uh wherever I wanted
without a boss
I have a deep horror of being bossed
around and that's Academia because
academic institutions in
most of History are remarkably
decentralized in the sense that
governance is not really that centrally
organized University presidents and
their British equivalents Vice
chancellors are kind of as powerful as
the queen is powerful I mean in the
British constitution in truth power in
Britain is in in the House of Commons
power and most universities is with the
tenured faculty and that meant that the
Republic of letters seemed very
appealing to me if I could become a
fellow of an Oxford or Cambridge College
then the world would leave me alone in
an agreeable study lined with books uh I
would be able to write those books
myself read the books of others
teach my thinking to Bright young people
and that teaching part was half the year
I mean three eight week terms I didn't
really even have to ask about the money
because as far as I was concerned the
salary didn't need to be that high I was
getting the office space and half the
year to write books and if I couldn't
make money from doing that then I made a
big mistake to begin with so that was
straightforward nothing else that was on
offer in 1985 when I graduated compared
uh with with that I'd have hated uh
Finance uh I considered journalism I'm
glad I decided to do that as a hobby
there weren't really any other things
that I thought much about
problem has turned out to be and I never
saw this coming in the 80s 90s or even
into the 2000s that that universities
have ceased to be places that prioritize
free inquiry quite the reverse may have
become rather as they probably were in
the Middle Ages places that prioritize
Orthodoxy and conformism and they now
exist to constrain thought and speech in
ways that are deeply repellent to me and
I think deeply dangerous for our society
so I've been forced to rethink my
relationship to Academia I I ended up
she seemed to be a professor I gave up
my chair at Harvard and came to the
Hoover institution six years ago I'm
senior fellow at the Hoover institution
I don't teach at Stanford partly because
they don't want me to teach uh and
partly because it suits me and now I'm
involved in creating a new University in
Texas the University of Austin in the
belief that we have to create new
institutions to model free inquiry
because the old institutions simply
won't repair themselves certainly not in
in my lifetime so that's that's been my
journey and when we think about you know
the vulnerability to disaster collapse
it strikes me that the university is
rather Cavalier at least um you know the
existential threats that they might have
I I recently did a project with some
friends uh physicist well-known Carlo
ravelli as well as uh the leader of the
Large Hadron Collider that CERN Fabiola
gianati and and other people where we
took Galileo's uh I'm known for my
finger puppets you know I hope you'll
forgive me this well we'll get one of
you someday but this is Galileo and we
took I took his Dialogue on the Two
Chief World Systems which was the
explication of copernicanism uh that got
him ultimately imprisoned although it's
not such a bad prison if you've ever
gone to uh archetri it's it's a actually
a place that Bernie Madoff would have
gladly traded places with old Galileo
but but the point being we took all of
his words we had them digitized and with
modern artificial intelligence engines
like gpt3 and others we could actually
you know have a simulacrum of of Galileo
that we could prompt and ask questions
of I think I'm a good professor you know
I think I'm above average although most
people think they're above average but I
don't think I can compare to to him or
to you know hair Einstein or or James
Clark Maxwell
um so what uh what advances will uh
University of Austin Texas what will
they make use of to differentiate or
will it be you know just just faculty
that are maybe estranged in some way my
friend Peter bagazian who's been on the
show as well as Lex Friedman who I know
I know they're involved but what
Innovations if any are they going to do
or is it going to be you know a a sage
scraping a piece of Rock and Another
Piece of rock uh you know just like they
did in below onion and 1080. well you're
right that universities have been around
in that form for a millennium and it's
time to rethink the model and we will do
that that's part of the fun of of an
Enterprise like this sure will will
attract uh some claudenka as the Germans
say some people who think against the
current and that's crucial and and and
and it wouldn't be worth doing if there
weren't people like Peter who clearly
need new a new home where they can do
their do their work freely I think there
are a bunch of innovations that that we
have in mind
one is to rethink the whole structure
departments are silos
and within those silos intellectual
corruption can run amok so we are
thinking more in terms of
interdisciplinary centers that will have
finite lives in our in other words it'll
be a shape-shifting institution where
we'll be trying to avoid the the
pathologies of the the modern University
uh in which there are sovereign
departments that engage in in
self-perpetuation of bad ideas
uh I think the second thing that that's
exciting to me is that we want to end
this notion of the campus as something
divorced from reality but accentuate and
emphasize the relationship between study
and uh subsequent activity let's stop
pretending that everybody's going to be
a professor that's not the case uh it's
not the case for the people doing phds
it's certainly not the case for the
people doing undergraduate studies let's
consider the very real uh point that
they have to play roles when they
graduate and let's begin that process so
I think the University of Austin will
have a lot of practice
and a lot of interaction particularly in
Junior and senior years with what we
call the real world uh so I think that's
a second important way in which uh in
which the institution will will be will
be different the third thing that I I
think we need to be quite uh open about
is that we want to pursue the
meritocratic ideal above all uh other uh
criteria for selection in the same way
that uh the military does I wonder where
the intellectual Navy Seals are today
I'd like to see the intellectual Green
Berets why is the military so
comfortable with its elitism and
Academia so uncomfortable with it to the
point that it is now throwing out uh
conventional ways of selection for our
academic merits so we are going to be I
think self-confidently interested in
intellectual elitism and that's going to
seem pretty refreshing compared with a
few other institutions that I could
mention today yeah I think they should
we should welcome the competition I I've
uh expressed my my optimism that it
succeeds I think competition is not just
good for you know better phones but it's
good for education and now with the with
the Advent of uh now monetizing all the
privately held debt uh for college
students I think there's going to be
less of an incentive for traditional
universities to rein in costs to cut
Administration and bureaucracy Etc well
uh you know we've reached the the end of
the regularly scheduled portion of the
podcast but if you'll indulge me and
slightly more forbearance for a few more
minutes I have three existential
questions that I'd love to ask you to
look into your crystal ball and also to
look back uh as as if through a
telescope if you wouldn't mind answering
what I call the thrilling three or the
Fantastic Four we will now play the
final three existential questions
[Music]
which begins uh and they're all in some
way related to Sir Arthur C Clarke the
first one has to do with this famous
quote uh any sufficiently advanced
technology is indistinguishable from
Magic which we open the podcast with if
you ever heard that voice it's not my
voice it's it's him and actually I don't
know if you knew those new but but the
word podcast comes from Sir Arthur C
Clarke I don't know that because 2001 uh
of course uh Dave asked how to open the
pod bay doors and the Pod is uh as as
what the iPod was named after uh by uh
Tony Fidel or Steve Jobs I can't
remember which one and of course
podcasts are played on iPods but not no
longer so the iPod doesn't even exist
anyway that's the connection to Arthur C
Clarke I think it's cute
um I want to ask you what if you had to
take any one object or learning or
wisdom from all of humanity with your
vast swath of history that you're aware
of what would you put on a monolith like
in 2001 those those menacing objects
that are maybe like time capsules from
an ancient civilization what would you
want to brag about or or just to say
that Humanity had discovered through its
course of existence for our future
civilization to find maybe in a billion
years
[Music]
well I've already done the the latins
and sums up The Human Condition so I
can't I can't reuse that I mean the key
insight
from my studies that technology changes
the nature of of life but not human
nature
and the fact that we can understand
thucydides and Shakespeare relatively
easily tells us that Human Nature has
changed staggeringly little over two
thousand years and that tells us the
limits of Technology you can you can
change the way that we communicate
clearly in the 18th century you and I
would have written letters to one
another and read one another's
Publications but we wouldn't really have
interacted that differently we're still
engaged in a kind of subtle Duel of
Minds
trying to work out which of us is
smarter it's probably you
um but that that's the key point that
people forget we're not that plastic
yes that is true and I think we're
underestimating I always say we have to
have a little bit of swagger but you
have to be humble at the same time as uh
as Gandhi said we should always keep in
mind that dust could crush us and not
that we always crush the dust and it's
interesting because Feynman of course
answered that question and you referred
to Feynman in the middle of the book and
the Challenger Affair but also for his
kind of Mr Smith Goes to Washington
awestchuck's type of attitude and he
said it was the atomic hypothesis that
you know everything is made of atoms
whirling around each other and I feel
like although as a physicist I have to
support you know I'm Duty bound to
support anything byman says or does but
at the same time I still feel like that
fails to grasp the sum total of what
makes Humanity as a whole so amazing so
precious so fragile and so worthy of
preservation and and yet I I as I said I
you know when I hear oh it's going to
change everything when we discover
actually I'm like you can go down to the
Pacific Ocean a couple miles from where
you or I are at different Parts the
Pacific Ocean scoop up life and it
doesn't change the fact that we're still
you know polluting the Earth and doing
all sorts of Devastation let alone all
the genocides of the last hundred years
uh should disabuse people okay next
question as another quote from Sir
Arthur uh he said when it's
distinguished but elderly scientist
states that something is possible they
are almost certainly right but when they
say something is impossible they are
very probably wrong I want to say ask
you Neil what um have you changed your
mind on and you're not a scientist but
let's say as a skull change scientist a
scholar uh what did you once think was
impossible uh and are now wrong about or
or what do you think that most people
have wrong uh or just in general what
have you changed your mind about when
have you been wrong
[Music]
foreign
but it's not because that's what
historians do
you I'm engaged in this activity at the
moment
with an enormous imaginative efforts I
travel every day back to the late 1960s
and early 1970s I'm writing a biography
of Henry Kissinger and I reenact in my
head what was going on what I can infer
from the surviving documents was
happening and in that process of
imaginess of reconstitution I'm engaged
in time travel I didn't believe this was
possible until my Ukrainian friend
Victor pinchuk said as he opened a
bottle of
it was a
1991 or 92 Bordeaux so the only kind of
time travel that's possible is this that
we we can travel in time with wine and
and that was the The Epiphany I suddenly
realized of course of course just as you
can taste the wine that was made uh in
1991 you can in fact reconstruct with
were imaginative uh Power What What In
fact was going on then and even further
back so time travel is possible it's
what I do I am a Time Lord science
fiction Doctor Who was my favorite
character still is in all of Television
it's the only television series that is
in fact worth watching forget Game of
Thrones it's history for morons uh
Doctor Who is a time lord and so am I
very good
um well yeah I I I often have said it
the other way around that that time
travel into the future is possible
um it's called your children and it
could be your biological children it
could be your ideological children of
which you and you have many many
millions around the world but the the
problem is that we're greedy because we
want to take our bodies and travel to
the future but no you can teleport your
values very deeply into the future and
uh maybe in a part two we'll we'll get a
chance to explore more about uh a
fatherhood I I can't resist asking you
and maybe this is more appropriate for
ION but but uh but you've you've
suffered a fair share of controversy and
and and
um you know there's an Italian
expression the higher you fly the more
people shoot at you or things like that
but I want to hearken to to George
Orwell not 1984 what you talk about in
Doom but but Animal Farm where you know
uh Ben the pig I forget the pig's name
but the
um the pig says to Benjamin the donkey
you know you're so resplendent you've
got the delightful tale
um uh you're so lucky I just have the
short more curly looking useless thing
it doesn't do anything and Benjamin the
donkey says yeah the good lord gave me
the tail to swat away the Flies but I'd
rather not have the Flies and not need
the tail uh telling you in your in your
life you've gotten so much you've had so
much courage you've done so many things
you also get a lot of criticism would
you trade the tale for the lack of flies
or or are you comfortable with this this
uh uh this trade that that you've made
uh in your life to be you know at The
Cutting Edge to be courageous but also
to take your fair share of criticism
well to vary the analogy uh you know
you're over the target when the Flack
isn't coming and my goal in setting out
to write history
to understand the way the world works
better was not to confirm what others
already thought but to challenge it
there'll be no point writing books that
simply replicated what previous authors
had said so by Design I set out to be
disagreeable and if there were no Flyers
buzzing around me uh if there were no
incoming slack I would be failing my old
Mentor Norman Stone once said to me
I wear my enemies like metals
is that's just the right way to think
about it so if any of my enemies are
listening uh Buzz on
buzz on flies
well now this has been such a delight uh
sharing your wet your wisdom this
phenomenal book do you know I can't wait
for your uh your your upcoming book uh
which which you've mentioned is about
Kissinger consume everything you do and
uh keep up the wonderful work and thank
you so much for coming on the into the
impossible podcast thank you Brian
thanks to a scientists for humoring a
mere historian it's been a pleasure
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]